اشتري ذهب سبايك ولا ذهب ديجيتال ولا
اشتري فضه ولا اسعار النفط بترتفع فاشتري
نفط احسن اشتري سلع اساسا ولا اشتري اسهم
طب لو اشتريت اسهم اشتري في البورصه
المصريه ولا البورصات الخليجيه ولا
الامريكيه ولا بورصه لندن ولا اليابان يا
ترى اشتري اسهم شركات كبيره ولا متوسطه
ولا صغيره طب ليه اشتري اسهم اصلا طب ما
اشتري سندات اذنات خزانه يا ترى اشتري
سندات اذنات بتصدرها الحكومه المصريه ولا
سندات واذونات خزانه امريكيه مثلا طب
اشتري شهادات ادخار من البنك واريح نفسي
بقى لا لا لا بلاش البنك انا هشتري عقار
العقارات هي الاستثمار الصح ولا ايه طب يا
ترى اشتري عقارات واجرها ولا اشتريها
وارجع ابيعها تاني بسعر اعلى الحيره
هتموتني اعمل ايه في القرشين اللي معايا
اللي التضخم عمال ياكل وينهش فيهم قبل ما
يطيروا كلنا شفنا عم اشرف عم اسطوات البلد
محتار ازاي لو انت محتار زيه ومش عارف
تعمل ايه في فلوسك فانا النهارده جاي اقول
لك هتعمل ايه بالظبط كل اللي كان عم اشرف
محتار فيه ده اسمه تخصيص اصول في المحفظه
الاستثماريه طبعا هتسالني حالا ايه
المحفظه الاستثماريه دي يا اشرف طالما
سالت السؤال ده يبقى لازم لازم تروح تشوف
حالا اول حلقه عملناها عن المحافظ
الاستثماريه لان اللي انا جاي اقوله لك
النهارده بصوص فلوسك وشقى عمرك وحياتك
مرتبط ومبني على اللي قلناه في الحلقه دي
هتلاقوها فوق هنا وهحط لكم رابطها في
صندوق الوصف برده ولكن سريعا كده من باب
المراجعه المحفظه الاستثماريه بتشمل اي
اصل مالي انت بتمتلك ذهب عقارات اسهم
شهادات بنكيه مشروع انت فاتحه لو عندك اي
اصل بيجيب دخل فانت كده عندك محفظه
استثماريه سواء كنت عارف ده او مش عارفه
المحفظه الاستثماريه هتساعدك على تنميه
ثروتك وتحقيق اهدافك الماليه وطبعا
اتكلمنا بالتفصيل في الحلقه اللي اشرت لها
حالا على المحافظ الاستثماريه ويعني ايه
والهدف من الاستثمار والافق الزمني ودرجه
تحملك للمخاطر وقفنا ساعتها عند اهم مرحله
في تكوين المحافظ الاستثماريه وهي تخصيص
الاصول وقلت لكم هنعمل حلقه كامله تكون
جزء ثاني عنها وده اللي هنتكلم فيه
النهارده مع بعض ان شاء الله فيعني ايه
بقى تخصيص الاصول ده وايه اهميته وايه
فئات الاصول والاستثمارات المختلفه وايه
الفئات الفرعيه اللي جوه كل فئه من دول كل
دي حاجات مهمه جدا جدا لازم كل شخص يكون
عارفها لانها اساسيات حياتنا الماليه
اساسيات الحفاظ على فلوسكم وتنميتها فازاي
هنقدر ندير الفلوس دي وازاي هنقدر ندير
الاصول اللي عندنا دي واحنا اصلا مش
فاهمين الاساسيات حتى صح فركزوا معايا
كويس جدا بقى يلا بينا نبدا انا اشرف
ابراهيم ده المخبل
الاقتصادي واحده من اهم لغات البرمجه
دلوقتي هي لغه بايتون انا شخصيا بفكر
اتعلمها لانها من لغات البرمجه الاكثر
استخداما في تعلم الاله والذكاء الاصطناعي
حرفيا بتجهزها للمستقبل وعلى فكره في
مواقع عربيه بتقدم دورات شامله باللغه
العربيه زي اكاديميه حاسوب اكاديميه حاسوب
بتقدم دورات في معظم مجالات البرمجه
وتطوير التطبيقات بيبدا معاك من الصفر
وبيطبل عملي وبالتالي هتنفذ مشاريع حقيقيه
وهتقدم شغلك ده في اي مقابلات عمل او لو
عاوز تشتغل عمل حر اون لاين لان حاسوب
عندهم مواقع خمسات ومستقل اكبر منصات
العمل الحر في الوطن العربي فما تقلقش
هيساعدوك تشتغل وفي دوره بايثون هتقدر
تبني تطبيقات حقيقيه وهتتعلم ازاي تبني
تطبيقات باستخدام اطر العمل زي جانجو
وفلاسك وغيرها وهتتعلم دمج تطبيقات الذكاء
الاصطناعي مع تطبيقاتك وحاجات ثانيه كتير
والحمد لله قدرنا ناخد منهم كوبون خصم ب
100 دولار لاول 20 هيشترك و في اي كورس
استخدموا كوبون الخصم اللي ظهر قدامكم على
الشاشه ده وهتلاقوه تحت الفيديو وفي
تعليقات فيسبوك برده هو ايه الهدف من كل
اللي بنعمله ده يعني ايه الهدف من المحفظه
الاستثماريه ببساطه شديده احنا لازم نعمل
محفظه استثماريه بغض النظر عن حجم ثروت
حتى لو بنمتحن مي ثروتنا دي او علشان
نحافظ عليها حلو طيب البناء بقى بتاع
المحفظه الاستثماريه دي الزلط والرمل
والطوب والاسمنت والحديد كل ده بيسمى
تخصيص الاصول الوكيشن تخصيص الاصول
بشكل بسيط خالص هي عمليه توزيع فلوسك بين
فئات اصول واستثمارات مختلف طب ايه انواع
فئات الاصول دي علشان نكون عارفين قبل ما
ندخل في فئات الاصول والاستثمارات ونوضح
الخيارات الموجوده داخل كل فئه كمان في
مصطلح في الاستثمار مهم جدا نعرفه مع بعض
قبلها لانه هيكون ملازمنا طول الوقت هو
ريسك ريتيرن بروفايل معناه بيان او نسبه
المخاطره والعاقد يعني ايه الكلام ده يعني
بيان نسبه العوائد المحتمله من ورا
الاستثمار يعني هكسب من ورا كام في مقابل
نسبه مخاطر خساره الاموال او مقابل
الخساير المحتمله اللي ممكن اخسرها من
وراها مبدا هنا ان العوائد المرتفعه دايما
بيجي معاها مخاطر اعلى وبالتالي المستثمر
هنا اللي هو حضرتك او اللي بيبنى المحفظه
الاستثماريه لازم يحدد موقفه يعني يحدد
مستوى المخاطره اللي قادر يتحملها علشان
يحقق العائد او المكاسب اللي هو عاوزها
لان تحديد نسبه المخاطره والعائد بيساعدك
على اتخاذ القرارات الاستثماريه الصحيحه
وبيوضح لك هل قرارك الاستثماري ده متفق مع
قدرتك على تح تمل المخاطر ومتفق مع اهدافك
الاستثماريه ولا لا وكنا اتكلمنا عن كل ده
بشيء من التفصيل في حلقه الجزء الاول من
محافظ الاستثماريه الفكره هنا بقى انك مش
هتقدر تعمل تخصيص للاصول والاستثمارات
وتبني محفظتك الاستثماريه من غير ما تحدد
نسبه المخاطره للعائد مبدا المخاطره
والعائد ده
هيتضرب ايه فئات الاصول والاستثمارات
والخيارات اللي داخل كل فئه خد عندك يا
سيدي الكاش والفئه دي بيندر تحتها اصول
نقديه زي الشهادات البنكيه وحسابات
التوفير الى اخره طبعا الفئه دي رغم انها
الاقل خطوره لكن العائد الحقيقي عليها
غالبا بيكون سلبي بمعنى ايه لو انت عامل
شهاده بنكيه بفايده 20% مثلا ومعدل التضخم
30% فبمجرد ما نقسم معدل التضخم العائد
هيكون سلبي وبالتالي قيمه الاصل ده هتخسر
10% رغم انها اسميا كسبانه خد بالك انا
هنا مش بقول لك تستثمر او ما تستثمر في
الاصل ده انا بوضح لك بس انواع فئات
الاصول والاستثمارات اللي موجوده في السوق
والخيارات اللي جوه كل فئه كمان ثاني فئه
اصول هي السندات وهي استثمارات ذات دخل
ثابت للي مش واخد باله يعني ايه سندات
السندات هي ادوات دين او قرض بيقدمه
المستثمر اللي هو هنا صاحب المحفظه
الاستثماريه
لمقتضي بيكون حكومه او شركه يعني انا ينفع
اسلف الحكومه اه ينفع وفي دول فيها حكومات
محليه اللي هي المقاطعات او الولايات
وبتقدر برده تصدر سندات يعني تقترض فلوس
من خلال السندات طب ليه بقول ان السندات
زاد دخل ثابت لان الشركه او الحكومه بتدفع
لحامل السند مبلغ محدد عباره عن فايده
بشكل دوري او عن عند الاستحقاق وبتعيد اصل
المبلغ في نهايه الفتره سندات الحكومات
بتكون اكثر امانا من سندات الشركات ولكن
العائد بتاعها بيكون اقل من عائد سندات
الشركات وده طبيعي على فكره كل ما زادت
الخطوره كل ما زاد العائد واكت سندات
مضمونه في العالم هي سندات الخزانه
الامريكيه لانها مضمونه بنسبه 100% من
الحكومه الامريكيه المهم علشان ما اطولش
في سندات دوليه برده زي الموجوده في
الاسواق الناشئه يعني انا اقدر اشتري
سندات بتصدرها الحكومه المصريه مثلا او
سندات بتصدرها الحكومه التركيه السندات دي
بيكون العائد بتاعها مرتفع واعلى طبعا من
العائد اللي بتقدمه الحكومات اللي
تصنيفاتها الائتمانيه عاليه علشان مخاطر
التخلف عن سداد الديون بيكون مرتفع فيها
سندات الشركات بتكون اقل امانا من سندات
الحكومه وطبعا العائد بتاعها اكبر لان
ببساطه ممكن الشركه تفلس وتتخلف عن سداد
ديونها وفي نوع خطير من السندات اسمه جانك
بونس او السندات غير المرغوب فيها ودي
سندات زي ما واضح من اسمها كده بتحمل
مخاطر تخلف عن السداد اعلى من اغلب
السندات اللي بتصدرها الحكومات والشركات
طب ليه لان غالبا بتصدرها الشركات اللي
عندها مشاكل ماليه حد هيقول وانا ايه اللي
يخليني اشتري السندات الخطيره دي يا اشرف
هقول لك علشان العائد بتاعها عوائد
السندات غير المرغوب فيها هي اعلى عوائد
على سندات في العالم تقريبا بس على
الناحيه الثانيه في مخاطر تخلف عن السداد
اعلى برده هنا نلاحظ مبدا المخاطره
والعاقد في عوائد محتمله ضخمه بس جايبه
معاها مخاطر محتمله ضخمه برده السندات في
منها انواع على حسب اجال استحقاقها وطرق
الدفع السند لو فتره استحقاقه من ايام
لسنه واحده مثلا بيسمى اوزون خزانه او بلس
وده الشكل الاكثر شيوعا في استثمارات
الديون في سوق المال بالمناسبه وبتسم
استثمارات قصيره الاجل اما لو فتره
استحقاق السند من سنه لع سنين فبتسم سندات
متوسطه الاجل او نوتس ولو فتره استحقاق
السند بتزيد عن 10 سنين فبتسم سندات طويله
الاجل او بانس وطبعا كل ما طالت فتره
الاستحقاق كل م كان العائد على الاستثمار
اعلى السندات اقل تقلبا واقل خطوره من
الاسهم بالمناسبه وده ياخدنا للنوع الثالث
من فئات الاصول وهي الاسهم الاسهم تعتبر
ركن اساسي في المحفظه الاستثماريه تقريبا
ما فيش محفظه استثماريه بتخلو من الاسهم
لان ببساطه لو قارنا الاسهم بالسندات مثلا
فهي رغم مخاطرها العاليه فهي بتديك اعلى
عائد
وبتتغندر خم لو بصينا على معدل العائد
بتاع الاسهم في البورصات الامريكيه مثلا
من اول ما امريكا بدات تجمع البيانات سنه
1926 ولحد سنه 2010 يعني على مدار ال 84
سنه دول هنلاقي ان مؤشر ستاندرد اند بورز
500 وده للي ما يعرفش مؤشر بيتت ابع اداء
500 سهم من اكبر الشركات الامريكيه
المدرجه في البورصات الامريكيه حقق متوسط
عائد ثانوي اجمالي قدره
99.7% يعني قرابه ال 10% في السنه متوسط
العائد على سندات الحكومه الامريكيه طويله
الاجل في نفس الفتره بقى كان
5.6% وبالتالي العائد على الاسهم بيتفوق
على السندات زي ما انتم شايفين ولكن ده
طبعا على حساب درجه المخاطر زي ما وضحت
طيب ده كلام حلو خالص ايه انواع الاسهم
بقى بشكل عام وفي اي بورصه في العالم نقدر
نقسم فئه الاسهم لثلاث فئات فرعيه بناء
على القيمه السوقيه للشركه فاحنا عندنا
اسهم شركات كبيره ومتوسطه وصغيره طب
عاوزين نميزه نعمل ايه ما فيش قاعده ثابته
هنا بس ممكن نميزه عن طريق المؤشرات اللي
بتكون موجوده في البورصات او القواعد
المتعارف عليها في البورصات الامريكيه
مثلا من ضمن القواعد المتعارف عليها
لتحديد الثلاث فئات من الاسهم كالتالي
الاسهم الكبيره هي الاسهم اللي بتصدرها
الشركات اللي بيزيد راس مالها السوقي عن
10 مليار دولار الاسهم المتوسطه هي الاسهم
الصادره عن شركات بيتراوح راس مالها سوقي
بين 2 مليار و10 مليار دولار الاسهم
الصغيره هي الاسهم الصادره عن الشركات
اللي بيقل راس مالها السوقي عن 2 مليار
دولار في البورصه المصريه مثلا هنلاقي
مؤشر اي جي اكس 30 اللي بيقيس اداء اعلى
30 شركه من حيث السيوله والنشاط في
البورصه وفي مؤشر اي جدي اكس 70 اللي
بيقيس اداء اعلى 70 شركه بعد ال 30 اللي
فاتوا وفي مؤشر تميز للشركات المتوسطه
والصغيره بورصه تداول اللي هي البورصه
السعوديه مثلا فيها مؤشر تداول للشركات
الكبيره ومؤشر تداول للشركات المتوسطه
ومؤشر تداول للشركات الصغيره طب تقسيم
الاسهم بالشكل كل ده هيفيدنا في ايه يعني
انا مالي اشتري اسهم شركه كبيره ولا صغيره
مش كلها اسهم وخلاص اقول لك لا ده مالك
ومالك كمان لان كل فئه من الفئات دي
بتختلف في معدل العائد ونسبه المخاطره
الاسهم الكبيره بشكل عام اكثر امانا ولكن
عوائدها اقل مقارنه بالاسهم المتوسطه
والصغيره اللي بيكون عندها قدره اكبر على
النمو المستقبلي ولكنها اكثر خطوره وممكن
ببساطه تخسرك هتقول لي امم بقى مهتم باسهم
الشركات الكبيره طالما بتدي عائد قليل
اقول لك ان استقرار اسهم الشركات الكبيره
دي رغم عوائدها القليله في الغالب الا
انها مفضله للمستثمرين اللي عندهم قدرات
اقل على تحمل المخاطر يعني حد زي عم اشرف
هيطلع على المعاش بعد 10 سنين مثلا ومعاه
تحويشه عمره فطبيعي مش هيحط جزء كبير من
فلوسه دي في شركات صغيره ويخاطر بخسارته
للفلوس اللي هو مش هيقدر يعوضها تاني دي
الفكره ببساطه في بقى تقسيم تاني للاسهم
بناء على مكان تواجدها هنلاقي عندنا
الاسهم المحليه والاسهم العالميه او
الاجنبيه طب ليه التقسيم ده مهم لاننا
مثلا لو هنشتري اسهم اجنبيه في سوق من
الاسواق الناشئه فا اسهم الاسواق الناشئه
بتوفر عائد محتمل كبير ولكن برض بيكون في
مخاطر عاليه لان الشركات هناك بطبيعه
الحال مرتبطه بالوضع الاقتصادي للدوله
الناشئه دي ممكن الدوله نفسها بتعاني من
تضخم او ديون كبيره مثلا فده بياثر على
اداء الشركات دي ممكن الاسهم تتراجع وتخسر
فلوسك في تقسيم تاني للاسهم داخل كل بورصه
بقى يعني هل هتشتري اسهم فرديه ولا هتشتري
اسهم في صناديق متداوله في البورصه اي تي
افس ولا هتشتري في صناديق مشتركه مضاره
ميوتشوال فانز كل خيار من دول ليه تبعاته
ويه تقييمه الخاص من حيث العوائد والمخاطر
مش هندخل في تفاصيل كتير بخصوص الاسهم
الهدف بس نوضح بشكل عام فئه الاصول دي
والفئات الفرعيه جواها فئه الاستثمارات
اللي بعد كده هي العقارات طبعا الاستثمار
في العقارات بحر واسع وفي اكث من شكل او
طريقه وكل حاجه منهم لها نسبه مخاطره
وعائد مختلفه عن الثانيه هنتكلم عن اشهر
شكلين بس في الاستثمار العقاري علشان
ماطولش وممكن نبقى نعمل حلقه كامله مخصصه
بس عن طرق الاستثمار العقاري لو حابين
تشوفوها عرفوني في التعليقات المهم الشكل
الاول هو منصات التمويل الجماعي العقاري
دي الستيت كراود فانن المنصات دي بتتحلل
المستثمرين انهم يجمعوا فلوسهم مع بعض
ويستثمر في مشاريع عقاريه اكبر من خلال
شركات تطوير عقاري عندها خبره في السوق
بتاخد نسبه اداره مثلا وبالتالي ده بيدي
المستثمرين ميزه كبيره انهم يقدروا
يستثمروا في العقارات بمبلغ صغير في مصر
مثلا لو افترضنا حد معاه 2 مليون جنيه
فالشخص ده صعب يقدر يستثمر في العقارات في
منطقه زي القاهره الجديده مثلا لكن لو دخل
معاه 10 او 15 واحد زيه معاهم مبالغ شبيهه
فيقدر يكسبوا الشكل الثاني من اشكال
الاستثمار العقاري وهي سناديق الاستثمار
العقاري او الريال استيت انفستمنت تراست
والمعروفه اختصارا بار اي اي تي عباره عن
ايه الصناديق دي هي صناديق تابعه لشركات
بتمتلك وبتدي عقارات مدره للدخل سواء كانت
شقق سكنيه او مباني تجاريه زي مراكز
التسوق او مباني اداريه وطبيه مثلا
وبالتالي الصناديق دي بتشتري اصول عقاريه
او بتبنيها وبعد كده بتاجر مش بتبيعها
علشان كده بنسميها استثمار عقاري موديل
للدخل في دخل شهري باستمرار بيتوزع على
المستثمرين الصناديق دي برض بتدي ميزه
كبيره للمستثمرين انهم بيقدروا يستثمروا
في عقارات مختلفه بمبالغ صغيره فئه الاصول
رقم خمسه هي السلع كومتس تقريبا ما فيش
برض محفظه استثماريه ينفع تخلوا من فئه
السلع والسلع هي منتجات ماديه نستثمر فيها
بهدف التجاره نشتريها لما يكون السعر قليل
ونبيعها لما السعر يزيد السلع ممكن تكون
مدخلات خام بتدخل في انتاج سلع ثانيه زي
النفط والغاز وممكن تكون سلع تعدينيه يعني
بيتم استخراجها من مناجم زي الدهب والفضه
والنحاس مثلا وممكن السلع تكون مواد
اساسيه زي المنتجات الزراعيه زي القمح
والقهوه والقطن والسكر وفول الصويا الى
اخره كل السلع دي نقدر نستثمر فيها بسهوله
وكل سلعه فيهم لها بيان المخاطر والعوائد
بتاعتها برده طبعا الاستثمار في السلع
بيحتاج اطلاع دائم على ظروف الاقتصاد
العالمي لان اسعارها بتتبني على محددات
عالميه شويه يعني مثلا حاله الركود
الاقتصادي بتاثر حاله النشاط الاقتصادي
بتاثر الكوارث الطبيعيه بتاثر على السلع
برده الحروب والصراعات والنزاعات بتاثر
قرارات السياسه النقديه
للفيدرالية فانت اكيد عندك قدره على معرفه
اتجاهات اسعار السلع بشكل محدس يعني لما
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه بدات فورا وضحنا
تاثيرها المستقبلي على ارتفاع اسعار
المواد الاساسيه زي القمح وبعض السلع
الثانيه ولما منظمه اوبك بقياده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اوبك بلس بقياده روسيا
يتفقوا على تخفيض الانتاج وده بنوضب
اتجاهات اسعار النفط فمعنى كده انه هيكون
في نقص في الامدادات وبالتالي متوقع اسعار
النفط ترتفع التغير رات المناخيه اللي
بنشوف تاثيرها العنيف على الكره الارضيه
دي من تسحر وفيضانات وغيره بنلاقي تاثيره
الفوري على اسعار البن مثلا لما الولايات
المتحده بتفرض رسوم جمركيه على صادرات فول
الصويا مثلا فبن عرف ان اسعار فول الصويا
هترت فع ازمه كورونا لما حصلت عرفنا ان في
ازمه كبيره هتحصل قريب في سلاسل التوريد
وبالتالي ده هياثر على شحن ونقل البضايع
فاسعار هترت بشده لنقص الامدادات لما يكون
الاقتصاد الع عالمي مقبل على تضخم كبير
فلازم نعرف ان المستثمرين في العالم بيتوا
للسلع للتحول ضد التضخم الفيدرال الامريكي
لما يبدا يثبت اسعار الفايده وبعد شويه
هيبدا يقلل الاسعار فلازم اعرف ان ده
هيعزل من السعر العالمي للدهب وهكذا علشان
كده لو انت اللي هدير محفظتك الاستثماريه
وقررت ان جزء منها هيكون سلع او كان في
مدير للمحفظه فلازم تكون او يكون مطلع
بدقه على ظروف واحوال الاقتصاد العالمي
وعنده قدره على التنبؤ وربط الاحداث
ببعضها علشان يقدر يدير جزء السلع في
المحفظه ويستبدله وفقا للاهداف
الاستثماريه اللي محطوطه فئه الاصول اللي
بعد كده هي العملات ممكن يكون مناسب ليك
ان جزء من محفظتك الاستثماريه تضم واحده
او اكثر من العملات الرئيسيه على حسب
اتجاهات العمله دي الدولار الامريكي مش في
كل الاوقات بيكون قوي زي الفتره اللي فاتت
دي احيانا بيكون ضعيف قصاد العملات
الرئيسيه الثانيه فمن مصلحتي ان جزء من
محفظتي تكون باليورو والعكس صحيح لان في
ازواج عملات دايما بيتنافسوا مع بعض في
سوق الفوركس زي الدولار واليورو مثلا فئه
الاصول اللي بعد كده ممكن تكون الاصول
المشفره وده بالنسبه للمستثمرين اللي
عايشين في دول بتسمح بتداول الاصول
المشفره اما الدول اللي بتحذر تداول
الاصول المشفره زي مصر مثلا فبن نصح
المستثمرين فيها باتباع قوانين البنك المر
الز المصري وعدم حيازه اصول مشفره الاصول
المشفره بتشمل مثلا العملات المشفره زي
البيتكوين والايثر والبل والرموز غير
القابله للاستبدال والمعروفه اختصارا
بالان اف تي اس الاصول المشفره من اشد
فئات الاصول الاكثر تقلبا واللي بيدخلها
في محفظته الاستثماريه فهو شخص عنده
استعداد كبير لتحمل المخاطر مقابل
احتماليه تحقيق عوائد اعلى مقارنه بفئات
الاصول الثانيه لان ببساطه ممكن استثمارك
في احد الاصول المشفره تلاقيه اتمسح
باستيكه في اي لحظه اخيرا عندنا
الاستثمارات الخاصه واللي بيندر تحتها
المشاريع التجاريه والخدميه زي المطاعم
وغيرها هنا طبعا لازم تعرف اذا كنت هتبقى
مستثمر نشط ولا سلبي وسلبي هنا يعني باسيف
مش نيجاتيف بمعنى مش شغال في المطعم بايدك
وانما بتكتفي بضخ راس مال فقط ومالكش دعوه
بالتشغيل طبعا المشاريع التجاريه والخدميه
بتختلف اختلافات ض خمه في ما بينها من حيث
نسبه المخاطره والعاقد فلازم يتم دراستها
من النواحي الماليه والفنيه والسوقيه كويس
دي كانت اشهر فئات الاصول اللي بيتم تخصيص
الاصول في المحافظ الاستثماريه على اساسها
ازاي بقى حبن المحفظه الاستثماريه بتاعتي
او تخصيص الاصول ده بيتعمل ازاي تخصيص
الاصول زي ما قلنا هو توزيع فلوسك بين
فئات اصول واستثمارات مختلفه من الحاجات
اللي وضحناها من شويه كل فئه من الفئات دي
بتتاثر ب شكل مختلف باتجاهات السوق
المتغيره دايما وبالتالي وجود مزيج منها
في محفظتك الاستثماريه هيساعد في تقليل
الخساير ومع فهمك لنسبه المخاطره والعائد
لكل استثمار هتقدر تختار وتعدل كل شويه
على المحفظه الاستثماريه بما يحقق الاهداف
اللي احنا عاوزينها يعني لو انت لسه صغير
في السن مثلا فتقدر تزود نسبه الاصول
والاستثمارات اللي بتحمل قدر عالي من
المخاطره زي الاسهم والسلع مثلا طب ليه
لان ببساطه انت لسه عندك وقت ان شاء الله
تعوض الخساير لو حصلت الاسهم مثلا مش
هتفضل تخسر للابد هيحصل تصحيح والاسواق
هترت تاني ولكن ده ممكن ياخد وقت طب انت
حد مسؤول عن اسره مثلا او خلاص قربت تطلع
على المعاش فهنا انت محتاج مصاريف شهريه
ثابته ومش هتقدر تتحمل مخاطر هنا هنركز
على محفظه معتمده على الدخل الثابت مع نسب
مخاطره قليله لانك ببساطه ما عندكش رفاهيه
خساره الفلوس ولا الاعتماد على الاصول
والاستثمارات ذات طابع النمو زي اسهم
الشركات الصغيره مثلا طب ازاي هقدر احقق
التنويع او دايفرز فيكيشن في محفظه
الاستثماريه ويعني ايه الارتباط السلبي في
الاستثمار وايه هي انواع المحافظ
الاستثماريه اصلا وايه الفرق بين الحسابات
البنكيه بتاعتنا سواء كانت حسابات ادخار
او شهادات وبين المحفظه الاستثماريه هنعرف
كل الحاجات المهمه جدا دي في الجزء الثالث
من محافظ الاست ماريه علشان مش عاييز اطول
عليكم اكتر من كده ما تنسوش تشتركوا في
القناه علشان تتابعوا الحلقات الجديده لما
تنزل باذن الله وعرفوني في التعليقات هل
نكمل بتفصيل اكت في سلسله المحافظ
الاستثماريه دي ولا نشرح المبادئ الاساسيه
بس ما تنسوش تشتركوا في دوره تعلم البرمجه
بلغه بايثون من اكاديميه حاسوب علشان
تكونوا جزء من المستقبل بتاع الذكاء
الاصطناعي ويا ريت لو عجبتكم الحلقه دي
تعملوا لايك وشير للفيديو وما تنسوش تحكوا
لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن يستفيدوا
سلام
[موسيقى]
ا